said what'd he say he said if i was with
him i'd wash his feet
and drink the water
hold on hold on this is really deep for
people who admire historical figures
like alexander the great and you know
they watch many of these movies uh
braveheart and many of these people out
there you know some are even fictional
but now heracles this is a real this is
not someone from the movies
no no the guy
gathered all of his priests and monks
and head of church
and ordered his guards to lock the door
and he recited to them
the stories and he recited to them some
of the verses
on uh isa peace be upon him jesus christ
and his mother
and his
miraculous birth
and the priests and monks started crying
until their beards were were wet
christians these are christians crying
now because they're hearing the quran
they are hearing the quran
and heracles heracles is setting up this
meeting now
now so
after that after he saw them being so
emotionally moved
by the truth of the quran he said to
them so what do you think should we
follow him
so he just
was testing the water in a in a positive
way
they
immediately overturned
because
their love of power
and love of wealth kicked in
she said and they started rebelling
against him no we will not do this and
so much chaos and
shouting and disturbance and he knew
this this is why he locked the door from
the inside so he said no no no no calm
down calm down i'm just testing your
iman if you're real believers or not
and everything went back to normal
so when this reached the prophet allah
salatu
he said in arabic
oh this wretched person he
was
favoring his wealth and power over islam
that's why he would not give it up
wow
this was unlike
unlike the reaction of the persian
leader
who torn the letter of the prophet
and rejected even to reply to him
because
uh hercules gave
the
messenger who came a gift
and a concubine and some jewelry
back to the protestant as a form of
honoring respect he gave he showed some
respect
to the
level to the level of he said i want
people to imagine this he said if i was
with him i would wash his feet and drink
that water
yes out of because
all christians know
of
the one that prophet
isa prophet jesus peace be upon him gave
the glad tidings of his coming
and
they knew that there was someone coming
to fix the world and jesus christ said
this in the bible and he said that he'll
come after me he will speak not from his
own self but he would speak from uh um
yeah i'm not a biblical historian so i
i'm not zakir knight either so you go
ahead and check it out can you get them
on the phone real quick
i wish i wish
i seriously i can't but
not at the moment
so
uh
you find
evidences that are beyond doubt
that they knew there was some someone
coming and we know who this someone is
and we can see it through his track
record
just open your eyes what do people hate
about islam
there are those who have
in it
in uh enmity against islam
like some european countries without
naming them
even
when the european council came yesterday
with an ad
showing a woman without hijab half
picture and a woman with hijab
half picture
to show the integrity the
um
how
cultures blend
in europe because muslims are a great
portion of the population in europe it's
an ad a woman with no hijab and a woman
with hijab they blend them in so half of
the girl is without and half is with
what happened this european country came
up front and said no this is totally
unacceptable we object because this
denies the christian and the jewish
heritage of europe
they have
hatred to hijab
anything that respects women they have a
problem with if a woman
comes out with a bikini or wearing a
thumb good for you that's the thing
that's what we like to see
they have no
fear no
bashfulness no shyness
they hate islam full stop
so you with a beard cut it
you wear hijab take it off
when corona came
people started wearing the mask
they they were shocked what can we do
they're wearing nikab legally
they couldn't do anything about it but
when it's out of your conviction out of
your belief out of your religion no we
have a problem